[Music]
don't you think i realize what's going
on here miss
who do you think i am huh don't you
think i know that if i was some hot shot
from out of town that pulled inside here
and you guys made a reservation mistake
i'd be the first one to get a room and
i'd be upstairs relaxing right now but
i'm not some hot shot from out of town
i'm a small reporter from rolling stone
magazine that's in town to do an
exclusive interview with michael jackson
that's going to be picked up by every
major magazine in the country i was
going to call the article
michael jackson is sitting on top of the
world but now i think i might as well
just call it
michael jackson can sit on top of the
world just as long as he doesn't sit in
the beverly palm hotel because there's
no
loudness excuse me sir it seems that we
do have a last-minute cancellation
uh there is a room available it's a
suite
but uh i'll only charge you the single
room rate thank you i'm sorry i got
upset it's probably from jet lag or
something i'm very tired i understand
what's the rate anyway uh that'll be 235
a night sir
[Music]
[Music]
one
i don't wanna
[Music]
wow
how come you don't like me what makes
you think i don't like you
you never talk to me at school you never
look at me
well maybe that's because if i did your
boyfriend would remove my lungs with a
spoon
chick cranston doesn't owe me i'm sure
he likes to act like he does
but he doesn't
do you want to kiss me
sunday
hey what is this someday
well i get the feeling you've been
kissed a lot you know i'm afraid i'd
suffer by comparison
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i need a couple of bananas how much are
they well the buffet plate is 12.50
you get peaches plums oranges and
bananas
all i need is a couple bananas
[Music]
go ahead take those bananas
forget it i'm not eating that take it
back certainly sir this really looks
great
can i get some uh extra mayo certainly
sir thank you
ready to go yeah
[Music]
there's the mercedes we get rid of that
stuff
[Music]
[Music]
i promise teach karate that to my part
you promise learn i say
you do no question that
you part dear
still this
fast wash all the car then relax
remember deal no question yeah wax on
right hand wax off left hand
wax on wax off
breathe in through nose out the mouth
waxed on wax off don't forget to breathe
[Music]
1 000 closing all power to the weapon
systems
no shields my guess is right they'll
have to de-cloak before they can fire
may all your guesses be right
[Music]
she's arming torpedoes fire mr scott
good shooting mr scott
precautionary to check off shields up
[Music]
i tried to think of the most harmless
thing something i loved from my
childhood
something that could never ever possibly
destroy us mr stay puft
nice thinking ray we used to roast stay
puft marshmallows
by the fire at camp wakanda
ray has gone bye-bye e-gun what have you
got left
sorry beckman i'm terrified beyond the
capacity for rational thought
[Applause]
nobody steps on a church in my town one
two three
[Music]
the rest is just the same isn't it
that doesn't really work does it
[Music]
did you try
shouldn't it be a bit more
this this yes
better what do you think
hmm
[Music]
you